[Music]  this is a big week for Viola Davis she's  nominated for a Golden Globe and this  morning she received a star on the  Hollywood Walk of Fame Michelle Turner  joined the celebration in the moment it  means so many moments since I joined 50  it's doing the work and as a result of  the work it's just my life is just  coming to fruition  Viola Davis looked incredible at today's  Walk of Fame ceremony receiving the very  first star of the new year it's an honor  to be here for my friend  violas close friend Meryl Streep was the  guest speaker she's possessed of a  blazing incandescent Talent I cannot  believe my life right now that Meryl  Streep spoke at my Hollywood Walk of  Fame ceremony with my handsome husband  and a beautiful daughter secure old  Genesis might just be my oldest biggest  fan Genesis is more of a positive  reinforcer whatever you want mommy  whatever you do you look beautiful